rated pg-13 deathtrap movie released in
January okay
[Music]
escape room so escape room is a thriller
horror movie no kind of footage escape
rooms they exist in the world there are
these rooms that have puzzles in them
and you got to get the clues and get the
key and then escape from the escape room
this is that premise but a group of
people are in this escape room they need
to escape we're dying they get done with
one room they go to the next room and
there are a few escape rooms different
scenarios different puzzles different
clues so it's pretty much the premise of
soft 5 right that it's the same bridge
saw 5 was exactly that premise
well whatever now we have this movie so
this is where I clarify by me saying
they exist in the world I mean they
exist in that funhouse capacitate ago we
solved it or we didn't solve it that was
fun let's do it again next week I'm not
saying murder deathtrap rooms that kill
you really do exist and real life that
we know of or maybe they do just no one
ever lives to talk about him so on to
escape room escape rooms pretty much
exactly what you think escape rooms
going to be given the description how
good do you think that's gonna be how do
you think it's gonna be actually might
be a little better than you might think
it's not the shittiest thing I've seen
in January it's just not as smart as I
would have liked to have seen from a
movie with this premise so some of the
characters are idiots so if they're not
idiots just unbelievable one dude in
here of course just has a chip on his
shoulder he's just an [ __ ] but even
with the nerdy kid everyone's given this
nerdy kid so much [ __ ] like I you're
never gonna have sex with a girl you
don't have sex with girls just like
people
it's 2018 this nerd is probably smashing
some hard MTG ass so an underestimate
I'm just sayin
but the [ __ ] in this movie is just an
[ __ ] to an unbelievable degree just
in terms of human nature this scene
where someone runs into an invisible
wall and he's like he's laughing at him
and if he just ran into a wall I would
get it invisible walled that you should
have some pause I get you might be
laughing on the inside but your
curiosity as to how the [ __ ] did he run
into an invisible wall that would I
think that would override it I would
supersede your want to laugh and you'd
be like how is that possible how did you
run into it there are invisible walls
now but nah he doesn't question you just
laughs some of the puzzles are pretty
clever pretty fun and I suppose it not
being as smart as it wants to be works
in its favor because it never leaves the
audience behind this you know you're the
audience you want to play along you want
to figure it out and you will always
figure it out before they do cool that
you can keep up cool that you know you
would survive these dead
I will say when the movies in the pocket
doing the puzzles I was having a pretty
good time and the movie wants to be more
clever than it actually is then it feels
like it's wasting your time actually a
part in this movie where the movie wants
to deal was something pretty
sophisticated but the execution on how
they chose to show it is a screw
positive you can have a neat concept but
you do still have to pull it off this
movie is like a relationship when it
keeps it simple it's remarkably
enjoyable when it tries to over
complicate things and you just want to
check out I'll say escape rooms a better
time if you're drunk
yeah no it's here's a story you want a
story story time I like puzzles once I
had this one puzzle it was really I was
on this thing for a while this locked me
up it was trial and error and testing
the variables I could tell I was
starting to get there this one dude was
at my place he's on his phone
he literally YouTube's the answer and
solves the puzzle right in front of me
before I knew he was doing that like
what a dick what a [ __ ]
what's shittier then youtubing the
solution of someone's puzzle they've
been working on and then solving it
right in front of them like [ __ ]
their wife like it's like [ __ ]
someone's wife solving someone's puzzle
via YouTube it's right there whatever
who's a dick move I'm just saying don't
cost me my puzzle but as for a scape
room have you seen it what did you think
about it or what's your favorite movie
or video game based on puzzle I did some
video games in there I feel like there
are more video games based on puzzles in
movies well whatever it is whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]